كما يظهر امامكم منذ قرابه الساعه ونصف
الساعه لا تزال عمليات النزول للركاب من
على متن هذه السفينه التجاريه
مستمره تبقى اعداد قليله من تبقى تصل
اعدادهم الى
350 شخص تمت عمليات الانزال بحسب الفئات
العمريه بدءا من النساء وذوي الاحتياجات
الخاصه او الاطفال والعائلات ومن ثم بقيه
الركاب تباعا وبحسب اعداد
المواطنين الاجانب بحسن تحدثنا سوف تبقى
الجاليه او المواطنين الاندونيسيين وعددهم
560 شخص سوف يكون هم اخر من سوف ينزل على
ارض قاعده الملك فيصل حتى يتم توفير
حافلات خاصه بهم ومقر سكن واحد سوف يقومون
بعمليه تسكنهم في مقرات واحده حتى يكون
بجو حتى يكونون بجوار
البعض لا تزال عمليات مستمره كما نشاهد
لاستقبال
بالورود وبالحلوى كما تشاهدون وذلك بوجود
عدد من القيادات الامنيه وممثله وزاره
الخارجيه السعوديه للتعامل وايضا وجود
مترجمين للتعامل مع مختلف الجنسيات كما
نشاهد الان الجميع هنا يحرص على استقبالهم
كما تحدثنا عن ابرز الارقام المتعلقه بهذه
الرحله نتحدث عن وجود اربعين بريطاني وسته
واربعين امريكي واكثر من 239 يمني
وسته وعشرين تركي وسبعه وثلاثين من
الجنسيه الباكستانيه وفقط من هم على متن
هذه السفينه 13 سعودي سعودي فقط
حتى هذه اللحظه اجلت السعوديه قرابه 2030
مواطن اجنبي من اكثر من 58
جنسيه تمت عمليه الاجلاء خلال ثلاثه ايام
الماضيه عبر خمسه سته سفن من ضمنها خمسه
سفن بحريه عسكريه تابع القوات البحريه
السعوديه وهذه السفينه التجاريه الاولى
التي حملت على متنها
1687 شخص تنوعت حالات الركاب بين عائلات
وكبار سن واصحاب ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه
كما نشاهد العائلات ونؤكد ان الحكومه
السعوديه بكافه قطاعاتها تتعامل مع كافه
الركاب على مستوى او مع كافه الرعاه على
مستوى الرعايه على مستوى واحد من الخدمات
والتسهيلات كما نشاهد الاغلب على مثل هذه
السفينه هم من العائلات ايضا بحضور وبوجود
عدد كبير من القناصر والسفراء لهؤلاء
المواطنين الاجانب لاستقبالهم وانهاء
اجراءاتهم برفقه الجهات الحكوميه السعوديه
لا تستغرق سوى الساعه واحده بعد نزولهم
الى ارض قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه ومن ثم
يتم نقلهم عبر حافلات تم تخصيصها او
اراء كوريه تحمل على متنها 39 شخص هم
جميعهم دبلوماسيين كوريين بمقدمتهم السفير
الكوري في الخرطوم كما نوها سابقا السفير
السعودي في الخرطوم ان عمليات الاجلاء
مستمره بالتنسيق مع كافه الحكومات
الاجنبيه ومع كافه الاطراف في السودان
لتسهيل ممرات امنه من الخرطوم برا الى
بورت سودان في مسافه تقدر ب 850 كيلو متر
هنالك في بورتسودان مقر للسفاره السعوديه
من خلال موجود يتم استقبال الرعايه وانهاء
كافه اجراءاتهم ليستطيعوا وصولا الى الى
ميناء بورتسودان ومن ثم اجلاؤهم عبر السفن
التجاريه وحتى عبر السفن البحريه التي
خاصه الحكومه السعوديه وصلت هذه السفينه
اليوم في رحله زمنيه وصلت
بلغت ثمانيه الى عشر ساعات لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات